In this video, we're going to show you how to send a boundary.
Let's first go into LLC sender.
So on the sender side,
you will find a blue comment box under here.
Let's look at it together and then
we can create our own boundary event together.
On the sender side,
we use this event here
to add three flows values as three separate LLC message,
and we will send them all out together as one bundle.
The use case of boundary is that we can send
multiple LLC addresses at the same time in one bundle.
So now, we can see that the first LLC message,
I'm going to use a address string that I
defined depends on the event input here.
I will add the first float into the message,
and then finally, the only difference.
So the first parts are very
similar to how we create an LLC message.
The only difference is that at the end,
we will add this event,
we will add this LLC message into a bundle.
We'll do it to the second LLC message,
add to the bundle,
third one also add to a bundle,
and finally, we will send this LLC bundle.
Once we send it,
we will then clear the bundle as well as all the messages.
Then move on to the receiver side.
Let's find the bind event to an LLC boundary received.
In the boundary side,
we will first get the different messages from the bundle.
So the first one,
we will get the LLC message from bundle at index.
It's very similar to how we get
index or get string from message at index.
Just instead of a float or a string value,
we're now getting an LLC message as an output.
So first, we will get the LLC message from index zero,
and I will convert the LLC address to a string,
and I'm going to use this string to
decide what I want to do with this bundle.
Let's create our own bundle.
Let's also first do a sequence,
and let's say for this one,
I'm going to create three.
I'll just make it simple.
I'll add two messages.
So first, I will just copy-paste from here.
I will create two messages that has
different string values.
I'll change this to be bundle slash string,
and I will make this.
So the message I want to send first,
I'll just say this is my first message,
and I want to add this to a bundle.
I'll do right-click,
Make OSC Bundle.
I will do Add OSC Message.
Actually, we can also see that there is
an option to add a bundle to a bundle,
so just make things even more complicated.
But for now, that's staying using Add messages to a bundle.
Now, let's do the second one.
The second one, I'm going to do the same thing,
but I will use a different address.
I'll say this one is a string number two.
For the message here,
I will say now this is the second message.
Now, we want to make sure
these two message are all sending to the same bundle.
So instead of doing that,
I'm going to create a variable.
So I'm going to say this is a OSC Bundle strings.
I'll just drag this out and replace the Make OSC Bundle.
Now, we make sure two messages are all added into this bundle.
I'm going to send it to my client.
Get OSC Client.
I'll do Send OSC Bundle.
Bundle I want to send is the one we just created.
Finally, we will make sure we clear the bundle.
Actually, not this one.
I'll just drag it out and do Clear.
OSC Bundle, like so.
Now, let's give it a event.
Let's say I wanted to submit a Send String Bundle.
Now, we have the event to send a bundle.
Now, we go to the receiver side.
On the receiver side,
whenever there is a bundle being received,
right now we have this just like
accustomed to the three-flow structure.
But we do have the ability to use
a switch on string to react to it based on the address.
So here, I'm just going to add
one more option on the switch on string,
and I'm going to use the same address here,
founder of string.
Once we have that,
I will get these two here.
Once we get that,
I am going to first grab the first message from it,
how to get string value from that index,
and then I'll do it again from the same bundle.
I'm just going to double-click to make a ping.
I'll drag from here.
So this output will be
the first string value we saved in the first message.
This one, we will do it from the second message.
So how to get string value from that index.
Finally, let's just do another print string.
Print string, just a lot of typo.
Print string, and I am simply going to use
append node here to put one,
and I'll just do an enter,
or just a lot of space, and the second one,
or actually just make it a little bit easier to see.
I'm going to print string twice,
and make it into different colors.
So for the first message,
I'll print in pink,
and in the second message,
I'm going to print it in purple.
That's good. So now,
once we receive a boundary with an address bundle slash string,
now I'm going to get the first message,
get the value out of the message,
which will be a string because I set it.
So a string will print it out as a pink string on the screen.
Then I'll get the second message from the boundary,
get the string, it will print as a purple one on the screen.
Now I will go back to the level blueprint,
and now let's do a B key, I guess.
Oops, not this one, B key.
Once I press B,
I want to send a boundary.
So now I will drag this,
and I'll do set string bundle.
So now we press B and we will fire
this send string bundle event on the OSC sender.
Now because we already bypassed
the thing that checks the launch parameter at begin play,
now when we're playing editor,
it's going to create a sender and a receiver in the same instance.
So now, if we hit play and I press B,
you should be able to see the print string.
Okay, yeah. So we see that the first message is being printed in pink,
and the second message is printed in purple.
So now all those are working.
In the next video,
we're going to move on to two-way communication.